[Musique]
on
débat sur france 24 les températures
mondiales ont une chance sur deux d'être
temporairement supérieur à 1 degré 10 me
dans les cinq années à venir selon les
nations unies l'organisation tire à
nouveau la sonnette d'alarmé alors que
la 15e coop contre la désertification et
l'appauvrissement des sols a démarré à
abidjan en côte d'ivoire la conférence
s'attaque à la sécurité alimentaire et
la biodiversité jusqu'au 20 mai 197 pays
dont une dizaine de chefs de l'état
africain sont présents emmanuel macron
et ursula von der leyen y participe via
une vidéo l'objectif c'est la lutte
contre la dégradation des terres qui
touche 40% de la surface de la planète
et qui affecte la moitié de l'humanité
la communauté internationale va-t-elle
se mobiliser alors qu'elle s'engage à
tendre vers un monde sans dégradation
des sols et à restaurer un milliard
d'hectares avant 2030 une telle promesse
nécessite un milliard et demi d'euros
quelle est l'ampleur finalement de cette
désertification et à quoi peut-on
s'attendre alors que les épisodes de
sécheresse touche la planète entière
famine pénurie les conséquences sont
multiples qu'elles répondent peut-on
apporter quelle solution mettant en
avant à abidjan pendant cette coop
sécheresse la prochaine pandémie on en
parle avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés arnaud gautier
bonsoir vous êtes directeur des
programmes wwf en france et vous êtes
également ingénieur agronome bienvenue
dans le débat en face de vous thomas
friands bonsoir économistes fondateur et
directeur général de l'institut open
diplomatie bienvenue à vous également
nous avons en duplex de bruxelles benoît
biteau euro députés du groupe les verts
vice président de la commission de
l'agriculture et du développement rural
au parlement européen vous êtes aussi
vous même vous possédez une ferme en
agroforesterie bienvenue dans le débat
également
en duplex d'abidjan nous avons notre
correspondant samuel bernard hamel
bonsoir on retrouvera également à
abidjan un peu plus tard dans cette
émission emmanuel seck
environnementalistes et puis nous irons
aussi à niamey au niger et au pérou
retrouvez nos correspondants pour faire
justement une sorte de panorama de cette
sécheresse mondiale la cop15 donc à
démarrer abidjan vous le disais en côte
d'ivoire un des pays africains les plus
touchées par la déforestation
90% de la surface de la forêt ivoirienne
a disparu ces 60 dernières années pour
comprendre ce phénomène nous vous
emmenons dans une forêt classée elle est
située à l'est du pays où plusieurs
villages se sont coalisés pour lutter
contre des planteurs clandestins de
cacao vous allez voir des planteurs qui
détruisent littéralement la forêt
reportage de notre correspondant à
abidjan samuel bernard pour faire fuir
les planteurs illégaux la méthode de ce
groupe anti déforestation est simple
dans cette forêt située à l'est du pays
le risque de l'altercation est réel
c'est donc armé et en nombre que les
membres de l'association sauvons la
forêt classée de bosser mathier
organisent leur ronde hebdomadaire
pour une question de sécurité parce que
[Musique]
à l'arrivée de ce groupe les planteurs
illégaux de cacao ont disparu reste une
zone de défrichage véritable cimetière
d'arbres à ciel ouvert dans cette forêt
classée les arbres sont tués en un an
grâce à cescau les autres on
[Musique]
avait collé tronçonneuse dans qu'ils
arrivent le feu et le feu fait son
travail quoi en disant 55% de cette
forêt située à l'est du pays a disparu
un gruyère forestier dont chaque trou
est une plantation de cacao clandestine
une catastrophe écologique à l'origine
de la création de cette association qui
rassemble dix villages aujourd'hui ces
communautés locales se sentent
abandonnés par leur gouvernement
personne au sol aucune autorité n'a pas
rêvé un petit téléphone lundi baujot et
ses mains de nous raconter malgré un
effort ces cinq dernières années l'état
a pris de nombreuses mesures pour lutter
contre la forestation
insuffisante selon ce chercheur qui
travaille depuis plus de 40 ans sur le
cacao en côte d'ivoire il estime que 40%
du cacao produit dans le pays seraient
issus des forêts classées pour empêcher
la disparition des dernières forêts
ivoiriennes il appelle à changer de
méthode l'état a approuvé son incapacité
à protéger les forêts et donc c'est sans
doute avec une partie de la population
qui a la volonté de la protéger qu'il
faut travailler alors que la cop15
débute en côte d'ivoire les membres de
l'association sauvons la forêt de bosser
mathier espère faire entendre leur
message
samassa mais bernard notre correspondant
à abidjan rebond soit vous suivez donc à
la cop15 qui a lieu à abidjan les
planteurs illégaux de cacao ça fait
partie des défis à relever en côte
d'ivoire et donc des sujets abordés à la
coop le pays la côte d'ivoire a perdu 92
% des forêts primaires depuis 1961
alors oui tout à fait alors la
déforestation en côte d'ivoire c'est un
sujet très sensible et ce qu'il faut en
fait comprendre c'est que derrière en
fête l'étang dire l'industrie du cacao
est un facteur voilà essentiel pour pour
comprendre ce phénomène vous avez
entendu les chiffres qu'a exprimée donc
françois russe 40% du cacao produit en
côte d'ivoire serait issu de forêts
classées donc des forêts protégées en
fait par la loi ivoirienne alors le
sosie de ses forêts de ces forêts
primaires en côte d'ivoire c'est que ce
sont des forêts est extrêmement fertile
gens des forêts qui sont donc très
rentable est très attractive pour des
planteurs illégaux ce que vous avez vu
dans le reportage c'est en fait un
phénomène qui date des années soixante
dix 1 le défrichage par des planteurs
illégaux c'est une tendance très lourde
et qui s'est accélérée dans certaines
forêts comme la forêt de bosser mathier
qui a donc perdu
on l'avait entendu dans le reportage 55
% de son territoire ces dix dernières
années alors il y a donc cette
déforestation cette déforestation qui
est donc d une agriculture familiale
clandestine qui sont donc le fait de
populations souvent venus du burkina
faso qui en fait sont des populations
pauvres qui viennent essayer de se
constituer un patrimoine terrien mais
donc il n'y a pas que cela ça c'est le
côté le côté populaire on va dire mais
il ya aussi le une agriculture qui est
un disons pas dans une déforestation
illégale qui est celle liée au trafic de
bois un trafic qui a d'ailleurs fait
parler de lui tout récemment puisqu'une
enquête de du confrère vincent duhaime
confrères donc à jeune afrique a révélé
qu'un audit pour trafic de bois visés
actuellement la sodefor la société qui
est en fait en charge de la protection
des forêts donc voilà voilà pour les
points on va dire négatif pour eux en
tout cas des points qui sont les
difficultés pour ce gouvernement qui a
pris des mesures malgré tout ces
dernières années des mesures sur la
traçabilité du cacao pour le lien est
direct puisque et voilà il ya cette
mesure ce projet d'un cacao zéro
déforestation il ya aussi des brigades
qui ont été mis en place des brigades
anti déforestation avec cette fameuse
brigade verte chargé donc de de traquer
les planteurs illégaux alors aujourd'hui
le président donc
annoncé ce plan à l'initiative d'abidjan
un plan à cinq milliards d'euros qui
doit réhabiliter les sols et les forêts
du continent donc
on voit là c'est une proposition
ambitieuse et mais malgré tout les
environnementalistes avec qui et qui
j'ai parlé donc salue cette promesse
mais attendent surtout des résultats sur
le terrain propositions ambitieuses
d'alassane ouattara merci beaucoup
samuel samuel bernard à abidjan
justement on va l'écouter le président
ivoirien
fication la sécheresse sans source de
migrations et le conflit inter
communautaire
à raison de la compétition au tour des
ressources naturelles en constante
diminution
dans ces conditions il est essentiel
d'adopter des politiques qui soutiennent
la résilience les populations notamment
les plus vulnérables
arnaud gautier une réaction peut-être à
ce qu'a dit justement alassane ouattara
il ya une autre statistique est sorti
aujourd'hui bien sûr ça ne concerne pas
seulement la côte d'ivoire à la fois la
déforestation la sécheresse le scénario
du business as usual comme on dit
conduirait à la détérioration
supplémentaire d'une surface de terre
équivalente à celle de l'amérique du sud
en 2050 c'est vraiment la sécurité
alimentaire du continent africain qui
est en cause
est exactement où vous l'avez dit à la
sécurité alimentaire du continent
africain mais aussi la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale qui est en cause à
cause de ces questions de
désertification et de dégradation des
terres on parle beaucoup de
désertification mais il faut aussi
caractérisé ce qu'est la dégradation des
terres on a des sols qui sont de moins
en moins productifs qui s'appauvrissent
et keith tout ça est et est accentuée
par le réchauffement climatique qui lui
est de plus en plus fort donc on est
dans un phénomène d'auto entraînement
mondial à moins direct mais je pas que
l'offre ils ne touchent pas que
l'afrique benoît biteau pour en parler
je pense mais en france on peut
considérer que certains sols de bosses
sont des sols dégradés sont des terres
dégradées ce sont des sols qui n'ont
plus de matière organique qui n'ont plus
aucun potentiel productif si on ne
ramène pas des engrais des engrais
minéraux pour revenir sur ce que disait
le président le président ouattara
certes c'est ambitieux mais vous avez
tous entendu les chiffres comme moi 90 %
de la forêt déforester coupés en côte
d'ivoire il reste plus grand chose à
sauver donc du cacao des zéro
déforestation en côte d'ivoire je n'ai
pas dire c'est facile mais il ya quand
même plus grand chose à sauver
aujourd'hui malheureusement côté
terrible à dire c'est terrible indien
d'où l'intérêt de restaurer aussi des
forêts de replanter des forêts pour
aussi sauver la production de cacao qui
souffrent le fait en fait d'avoir coupé
les forêts génère du stress sur la
production de cacao qu'un homme qui a
besoin d'ombré et ils ont de gros
problème agronomique aujourd'hui en côte
d'ivoire dias à benoît biteau vous êtes
député européen mais vous avez aussi une
ferme en agroforesterie c'est ce
qu'arnaud gauffier signifier vous
constatez donc vous même un
appauvrissement des sols y compris en
france
où tirer la sonnette d'alarmé ce soir
oui absolument
bien sûr on a on a tiré avec cette
agriculture productiviste intensive
basée sur l'utilisation des substances
de synthèse les engrais les pesticides
on a par les pesticides et les engrais
de synthèse tuer la vie des sols qui
participent à leur bon état qui
participent à leur fertilité donc ça
c'est un premier constat le deuxième
constat c'est que on a affaibli en
matière organique ses sols et donc on a
on est en train de perdre la fertilité
de cessole on ne voit bien sur les
démarches qu'on appelle ici à l'union
européenne de carbon farming on aaron
disposent de cartes aujourd'hui où on a
des potentiels de stockage du carbone et
ceux qui ont le plus gros potentiel de
stockage de carbone aujourd'hui sont
ceux qui sont dégradées c'est à dire
effectivement le bassin parisien la
beauce l'abri la vallée de la garonne où
cette carte montre qu' on a complètement
dans des logiques court termiste
affaibli la fertilité de ses sols et on
voit d'ailleurs les rendements commencé
à s'inverser sur ces zones là thomas
friands une réaction peut-être vous êtes
l'économiste de ce plateau
l'appauvrissement des sols concerne tous
les continents c'est ce qu'on sait
également consacre vous faites c'est la
réalité vous avez raison 1 70% des vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de chiffres un
peu différent mais 70% des 75% des
écosystèmes terrestres sont affectés par
l'économie humaine avec en effet des
pertes de rendement de l'école des
économies entières qui s'effondre sur le
sujet spécifique de la cop15 contre la
désertification ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ils ont choisi la proche
régénératif c'est-à-dire d'apporter des
solutions en matière de restauration de
forêt puisque en fait ce qui se joue
c'est la disparition des forêts dans
toute la bande sahélo saharienne les
objectifs qui sont énoncés sont
extrêmement ambitieux mais ils sont pas
comment dire pas à la hauteur pas tout à
fait conforme de ce que déjà au niveau
des nations unies dès 2014 avec la
déclaration new york où on fixait et si
je rappelle le fameux défi de bonn qui
fixe les objectifs mondiaux en termes de
restauration de forêt on est à 350
millions d'hectares on est très loin de
ça il faudrait investir pour y parvenir
400 à 600 milliards d'euros d'ici 2015
beaucoup plus que 1,5 alors regarde là
c'est alassane ouattara c'est l'objectif
de la côte d'ivoire donc à l'échelle de
la côte d'ivoire c'est extrêmement
ambitieux il faut saluer cet effort là
mais c'est aussi un appel à la
mobilisation générale de la communauté
internationale y compris parce qu'il ya
des bénéfices extrêmement important sur
le plan économique je rappelle cette
étude du forum économique mondial qui
est sorti de cette année qui explique
quand on restaure correctement avec tous
les bons principes environnementaux pris
en compte qui ont été dictées ya à peine
30 ans dans les principes de rio au
sommet de rio au sommet de la terre
quand vous investissez un dollar dans
une forêt bien restauré vous pouvez
générer jusqu'à 30 dollars de valeur
ajoutée a distribué dans les communautés
locales donc ça aussi un vecteur
d'espoir qu'il faut entendre cet
investissement c'est parce que des
engagements qui ne sont pas tenus en
tout cas depuis lors ce que c'était
toutes ces années vous allez retrouver
emmanuel seck vous êtes en direct avec
nous d'abidjan environnementalistes
coordinateur du programme à enda énergie
c'est une ong sénégalaises merci d'être
avec nous il ya cette image finalement
qui a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
et qui a beaucoup choqué cette image des
girafes c'est la première fois en fait
qu'on voit des girafes mourir à cause de
la sécheresse ça a beaucoup fait ça
beaucoup entraîné sa entraîné de fortes
réactions elles ne seraient elles
seraient plus de 100000 dans toute
l'afrique ces girafes c'est d'ailleurs
cinq fois moins que que les éléphants là
ça se passe dans la corne de l'afrique
cette sécheresse qui menacent d'ailleurs
de famine 20 millions de personnes le
kenya la somalie et l'ethiopie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui puisque vous êtes
à cette coque vous êtes sur place est ce
que vous tirer la sonnette d'alarmé à ce
que finalement les conséquences les plus
directs sont justement la famine des
humains et des animaux
oui merci je vous remercie donc de me
donner l'opportunité d'intervenir sur
votre plateau effectivement nous étions
depuis hier un segment de haut niveau
oui un appel a été lancé donc un appel
forte pour davantage considérer la
question de la sécheresse de la
désertification au niveau de différents
pays qui sont affectés notamment les
pays de la corne de l'afrique donc vous
l'avez tantôt cité mais disons c'est
c'est sécheresse ne l'affecté pas
uniquement et donc la flore ou à la
faune beaucoup d'humains sont concernés
vous voyez certainement dans certaines
zones des déplacements de population
massifs d'ailleurs donc vers des
territoires donc qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus prospère il faut pas oublier ce qui
s'est passé aussi à madagascar et au
mozambique où on a eu quand même dix ont
des impacts très marqué sur sur les
populations donc je pense qu'il ya eu un
appel donc des chefs d'état des
ministres pour davantage considérer ces
questions de sécheresses désertification
et même de déforestation parce que
j'entends parler de la question de la de
là
foresterie des questions aussi
d'engagement et d'engagement des jeunes
et des femmes mais des questions de
migration parce qu'il faut pas oublier
une épée dans beaucoup de zones qui sont
affectées par la désertification
les populations sont en train de quitter
les localités dont pour venir
certainement en ville ou bien après les
villes ils vont ils vont traverser la
méditerranée pour regagner l'europe et
d'autres zones qui sont des zones les
plus les plus prospères un objet vous
pouvez rebondir sur cette question des
réfugiés climatiques on en parle plus on
sait très bien que ça va être vraiment
une très grosse problématique en tout
cas dans les années qui viennent comment
faire face oui c'est une c'est une
problématique qui arrive avec le
réchauffement climatique avec la
dégradation des terres comme comme ça a
été dit on a face à nous des vagues de
migration de plusieurs centaines de
millions de personnes à travers le monde
notamment liés à ces phénomènes il ya
une initiative qui il faut saluer qui a
été lancé par l'union africaine ya
quelques années 2014 qu'est la grande
muraille verte qui vise justement à
combattre ces migrations en essayant de
fixer les populations en leur apportant
des revenus en leur apportant aussi des
terres qui sont plus productives la
grande muraille verte c'est quoi ça
consiste à financer la plantation
d'arbres depuis la mauritanie jusqu à
l'erythrée donc ses limites km c'est une
frau en fait ça va d'est en ouest or on
va regarder on a trouvé une carte 8000
kilomètres mais elle peine à se
concrétiser cette muraille verte puisque
j'ai vu qu'il n'ya que entre 4 et 20 %
de l'objectif qu'ils soient réalisés ça
démarre ça démarre on a eu quand même
une impulsion forte 1 ces dernières
années notamment par le sénégal le
sénégal a engagé de gros gros programme
de reforestation dans le cadre de la
grande muraille verte donc c'est parti
il manque de financement on l'a dit tout
à l'heure les financements sont pas là
sont pas à la hauteur du défi de la
restauration des terres que ce soit sur
la plantation de nouvelles forêts de la
reforestation sur de la restauration de
terres agricoles dégradées on a des
centaines de millions d'hectares des
milliards d'hectares qui sont dégradées
à travers le monde on connaît les
techniques pour restaurer planter des
arbres pour restaurer des forêts mais
aussi restaurer des terres agricoles
qu'ils soient productives et qui
permettent aux personnes gens de vivre
de leur production agricole et de rester
sur le territoire qui les ont vu naître
thomas frey en un mot sur cette muraille
verte bien sûr c'est toujours le en ce
moment qui manquent et puis peut-être
aussi les frontières entre les
différents pays les conflits ça
l'arrangerait réseau mondial il ya de
définir à la fois il ya un défi
économique de faire advenir sur le
terrain les financements qui ont été
engagés parce qu'en réalité
politiquement les engagements ont été
pris notamment lors du one planet ce
mythe dédiée à la biodiversité qui a eu
lieu en janvier 2021 et c'est peut-être
ça qui est intéressant d'observer dans
la raison de la venue du président la
république emmanuel macron pour voir
s'il va veiller au respect des
engagements qu'il avait chaperonner à ce
moment là et le deuxième défilé
géopolitique parce que cette bande
sahélo saharienne qui va de dakar à
djibouti en plein milieu on a le mali le
tchad toute la zone du sahel dans lequel
la france est en train de perdre
une capacité d'appui technique
à ces bourgs en prob de restauration et
de reforestation qui sont le principal
outil pour lutter contre la
désertification le plus grand programme
le plus ambitieux quand justement va à
niamey tout de suite retrouvé aroldi
rares notre correspondant à rolle de
bonsoir alors vous au niger vous avez
fait un reportage sur l'accès à l'eau le
niger a connu une sécheresse la plus
forte sécheresse depuis dix ans c'était
l'année dernière votre constat il ya
près de 40% des rendements agricoles en
moi en 2022 par rapport à la moyenne des
cinq dernières années alors pourquoi
pourquoi parce qu'en fait la
désertification c'est une crise qui ne
peut pas être endiguée endiguer d'un
coup d'un seul c'est pour que c'est pour
ça que les statistiques prennent
beaucoup de temps à sortir ces cinq
dernières années c'est l'onu des
institutions internationales mais aussi
l'état qui ont voulu faire remonter les
chiffres et on atteint bas ce chiffre
désastreux en 2021 de 40 % de rendement
agricole en moins alors pour une
population qui est à 80%
survie par l'agriculture qui pratiquent
une agriculture de subsistance et à dire
qu'ils se nourrissent eux mêmes mais
aussi leurs familles c'est un drame en
fait on peut pas l'appeler autrement ça
produit directement un chômage mars
massif par endroits au niger mais aussi
une inactivité qui se généralise sur le
territoire et un exode rural vers ces
villes ces populations qui viennent dé
mieux et des milieux ruraux lorsqu'elle
arrive en ville en fait lorsqu'elle
arrive dans une capitale comme celle de
niamey elles n'ont pas les
qualifications nécessaires pour survivre
en fait dans le milieu professionnel
n'ont pas de qualification dans le
milieu tertiaire et malheureusement
elles viennent rajouter une couche de
pauvreté à la ville une couche dans les
secteurs qui sont le plus les quartiers
qui sont le plus touchés par la
mendicité
cette perte unique de l'heure cette
perte de leur activité unique elle se
traduit aussi par un problème que
beaucoup voient venir depuis longtemps
c'est qu'il ya de plus de plus de plus
en plus de gens au niger il y aura
bientôt 30 millions de personnes à la
fin de la décennie contre 24 millions
non c'est un problème qui ne s'arrête
pas et tout ça dans un contexte
écologique qui se dégradent alors la
première activité qui est l'agriculture
qui perd de plus en plus de personnes de
travailleurs à cause des conditions et
les villes qui gagnent de la pauvreté
tout ça ce tout ça est un gros problème
pour le gouvernement qu'on essaie de
rattraper mais la grosse ironie en fait
c'est que c'est toutes ces personnes qui
vivent dans des milieux ruraux sont
assis littéralement sur des nappes
phréatiques très riche au niger en fait
dans le sous sol nigérien il y a
beaucoup d'eau mais les moyens
logistiques les moyens financiers pour
exploiter ces ressources sont bien loin
de la portée de ces populations rurales
qui doivent attendre l'aide des ong de
l'état des structures internationales et
on voit même n'être en fait des
frictions entre les gens qui aident et
des gens qui se font aider puisque ces
populations subissent des problèmes qui
sont de plus en plus urgent des puits
qui s'assèchent comme on peut le on peut
le voir dans le tournage de l'effet et
de l'autre côté les associations les ong
ont des réponses qui ne peuvent pas
aller à la vitesse de la progression de
la désertification
ici au sahel merci harold à redire à en
direct de niamey emmanuel seck vous êtes
toujours avec nous à abidjan on voit
bien que la gestion de l'eau est
fondamental et que malheureusement cette
sécheresse provoque des conflits de
nombreux conflits locaux c'est ce que
nous disait un rôle dirar plus en
ajoutant effectivement les réfugiés
climatiques ça fait beaucoup de troubles
oui mais il faut juste comprendre que
aussi ses zones de désertification qui
sont arides ou semi arides
ont des potentialités donc ils ont des
potentialités énormes donc vous pourrez
comprendre que dans le domaine agricole
qu'on puisse au moins se mettre en place
des modèles ou des business au niveau de
la transformation c'est à dire avec
certaines chaînes de valeur si l'on
prend par exemple au niveau du
pastoralisme de l'élevage on peut
prendre la chaîne de valeur les a donc
ok produites durant les saisons de
pluies dans certaines zones dont qui
sont affectées par la désertification où
on peut créer par exemple de petites
unités donc solaire de collecte et de
stockage de l'est après maintenant c'est
de mettre des micros entreprises pour la
transformation de ces produits là vous
comprendrez ou que vous conviendrez avec
moi que la zone du sahel est une zone
aussi où on trouve suffisamment donc de
balanites est donc on appelle le dattier
du désert avec lequel on peut avoir des
sous produits dont twitter pour
l'alimentation pour le cosmétique époux
bien pour la médecine dont il ya
vraiment d'opportunités dans ces zones
là et on l'a souligné tantôt en parlant
de la grande muraille verte la grande
muraille verte pour nous on le voit cela
au delà donc de la reforestation
il faut qu'on arrive réellement à créer
des pôles de développement rural intégré
c'est à dire voir i kissed quels sont
les obstacles
quels sont les étudiants qui est de la
faire
emmanuel seck les obstacles on l'a on la
cité donc un des premiers obstacles
c'est la question donc de la ressource
en eau pour avoir l'eau dans ces zones
là il faut aller vers la nappe
phréatique sinon et cela demande des
moyens techniques les forages que nous
avons présentement fonctionne avec le
gasoil et nous ce que nous nous mettons
en avant ses complices solarisé donc ces
forages l'a donc qui contrôlerait d'une
manière comme une autre déjà à la
réduction donc des émissions avec parce
que nous connaissons savons tous que le
combustible fossile contre lui disons
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dont il ya cette question d'accès à
l'eau mais il ya aussi ces questions
donc d'orientation politique parce que
nous avons toujours vu les collectivités
ou les localités comme des pourvoyeurs
de matières premières et les
investissements ou la transformation se
fait souvent au niveau de vie il faut
que ces ces zones là puissent avoir des
installations dont qui puisse leur
permettre aux maîtres de développer
certaines activités notamment ce que je
disais les les petites entreprises dont
qui impliquerait davantage aimé
professionnalisation c'est à dire des
organisations paysannes des
collectivités de femmes par exemple puis
travaille sur certaines sur certaines
activités ou certaines domaine et qui
rendrait beaucoup plus prospère ces
zones là notamment ceux qui se trouvent
au niveau du tracé de la grande muraille
verte donc pour nous la grande muraille
verte va au delà de la frustration
mais constitue une opportunité vraiment
d'affaires et de développement des
populations au niveau local pourvu qu'on
arrive à maîtriser 10 ans l'accès à
l'eau donc l'ex look est donc
fondamental à vous le dit on va quitter
le continent africain pour aller
justement retrouver nicolas nicolas
pardon thomas ni colons à lima au pérou
c'est notre correspondant dans la région
correspondante donc au pérou mais aussi
au chili thomas vous êtes avec nous
alors au chili les lacs sont presque
tous à sec près de 50% des municipalités
du pays sont déclarés en pénurie d'eau
le chili est donc confronté à une méga
sécheresse et la population de santiago
ce qui est tout de même assez incroyable
contraintes maintenant à des
rationnements drastique d'eau comment
l'expliquer justement au chili
alors la sécheresse qui frappe le chili
depuis 13 ans déjà s'explique
principalement par deux raisons d'abord
et c'est la raison la plus importante
c'est le réchauffement climatique les
rivières et les lacs qui entoure la
capitale santiago se sont asséchés il y
à la rivière mapocho par exemple qui
traverse la ville de santiago qui a vu
son débit baissé de 57% en 2021 2021 qui
a d'ailleurs été l'année la plus chaude
enregistrée
dans la région avec des températures
allant jusqu'à 50 degrés en argentine
ces derniers mois la deuxième raison qui
explique cette sécheresse c'est le fait
que l'eau et d'un bien privé au chili un
bien marchand pour reprendre les mots de
l'organisation greenpeace les droits
d'exploitation de l'osce ont morcelé
entre différents entreprise et sa
rentrée difficile l'élaboration d'un
plan commun et puis
il y à la rédaction en réaction à au
fait que l'eau soit un bien privé il ya
en ce moment la rédaction d'une nouvelle
constitution au chili et il est prévu
qu'il y soit indiqué que l'eau est un
bien que ce soit en bien commun et non
un bien privé et la population chilienne
va voter pour valider ou non cette
nouvelle constitution en septembre
prochain alors comment fonctionne le
rationnement au chili et dans la
capitale santiago il ya un an un système
d' alerte en trois étapes d'abord c'est
les restrictions sur les eaux non
indispensables le deuxième niveau c'est
une reste une réduction du débit au
robinet est le troisième niveau et bien
ce sont des coupures d'eau qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 24 heures et le système
est un système de rotation pour que un
quartier ne soit pas affectée par cette
coupure d'eau deux jours de suite le la
sécheresse au chili entre donc dans sa
treizième année le gouverneur de la
ville a rappelé qu'il s'agissait d'une
situation sans précédent et qu'il
fallait se préparer à ce qu'il n'y est
tout simplement pas assez d'eau pour ce
pour tous ceux qui vivent dans santiago
et dans sa région donc voila c'était pas
seulement en afrique mais également donc
en amérique latine merci beaucoup
tomates on manie colons dont vous étiez
à lima au pérou avec nous à arnaud
gautier retour en europe l'agriculture
est dans le viseur dont justement les
causes elle est responsable de 80% de la
déforestation 70% de la consommation
d'eau douce comment la rente ont plus
durable alors la rendre plus durable il
ya énormément de possibilités pour notre
agriculture plus durable d'une part vous
parliez la déforestation cette
déforestation est là lui essentiellement
sur le continent sud américain en
afrique et en asie du sud est elle est
liée à nos modes de consommation
en tant que pays développés notamment
donc une façon de lutter contre cette
déforestation liée à l'agriculture c'est
de manger des aliments qui ont besoin de
moins d'espacé pour être produit c'est à
dire manger moins de protéines animales
au sens large - de viande en particulier
- 9 - de poulets nourris au soja
brésilien donc il faut tout revoir nous
faut tout revoir beaucoup plus
végétalisée notre assiette ça c'est en
tant que consommateur et après sur les
modes de production là on a énormément
de levier entre nos mains sur
l'agroécologie éviter d'avoir des sols
qui soit laissé à nu l'hiver ou l'été
d'avoir des sols qui sera couvert en
permanence remonter le taux de matière
organique des sols pour améliorer leurs
capacités de stockage de la
contradiction justement entre la
nécessité de la productivité de
l'agriculture y compris en europe via la
pac on voit qu'aujourd'hui justement
aider il faut accélérer parce qu'il ya
une guerre en ukraine donc on n'a plus
ses exportations et justement cette agro
écologie qui demandent peut-être plus de
temps un traitement différent des sols
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une contradiction
alors c'est une vraie question c'est une
vraie question que beaucoup se posent et
qui est beaucoup mis en avant notamment
par la fnsea le syndicalisme agricole
majoritaire comme on dit mais les stocks
sont là les stocks de céréales sont là
aujourd'hui c'est plus un problème de
commerce mondial de déblocage des stocks
la fao l'a montré dans ses prédictions
la deux de production sur les céréales
cette année là et fao en 2022 prévoit
une prune prévisions de production de
céréales en hausse par rapport à 2021 le
problème c'est qu'on va avoir des
restrictions à l'export en russie par
exemple donc ces céréales ne vont pas
forcément atteindre les marchés qui en
ont qui en ont besoin d'autre part le
canton passent au bio par exemple on a
une chute de rendement effectivement en
produit moins à l'hectare mais derrière
si on consomme moins de protéines
animales qui sont guy nécessite
énormément d'espacé on peut tout à fait
compensé cette perte de rendement est
encore une fois fillon il ya une perte
de rendement dans beaucoup de cas mais
elle n'est pas systématique on a des
techniques en bio qui permettent de
produire autant voire plus en combinant
des en combinant des cultures notamment
benoît biteau justement est-ce que vous
pouvez réagir sur ce que vient de dire
arnaud gautier vous j'imagine que vous
prenez ce type d'agroécologie
même si parfois il peut être le
traducteur avec sept jours oui non non
non je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
c'est ça c'est les études qui sont
conduits par les détracteurs d'une
agriculture qui fait référence à
l'agroécologie et qui sont en train
d'instrumentaliser la crise géopolitique
en ukraine c'est à dire que en vérité il
n'y a pas de sujet sur la profession et
la possibilité d'approvisionner des
populations qui étaient
traditionnellement des clients d'ubs les
ukrainiens ou du blé russe il suffit par
exemple de re de redéployer les 20% de
céréales qu'on met dans le réservoir de
nos voitures et on a du blé pour nourrir
les égyptiens on peut aussi et je
rejoins complètement ce qui a été dit
réduire notre notre alimentation carnée
notre alimentation laitière aussi parce
que le lait est aussi une protéine
animale qui consomment beaucoup de soja
par exemple et on libère des productions
pour satisfaire les besoins veut dire
modifier d'ici
modifié mais pas seulement notre notre
style de vie c'est à dire qu'on peut
aussi manger de du du lait ou de la
viande qui sorte d'animaux qui sont des
herbivores et qu'ils mangent de l'herbe
est ce que vous vous rendez compte de la
révolution que je vous propose c'est me
faire manger des herbivores à faire
manger à des herbivores de l'herbe c'est
des fondamentaux c'est ce que faisait
mon grand père qui était né au 19e
siècle donc revenons à des fondamentaux
et vous verrez que ça va bien se passer
et on a lu véritablement des cercles
vertueux c'est à dire que les sols qui
sont en train de se dégrader avec des
logiques basé sur le maïs et le soja de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique pour
nourrir des animaux va se reconstituer
si on iran mais de l'herbe si on y remet
des prairies on va trouver une
alimentation de bien meilleure qualité
si on nourrit dr vivent avec de l'air
donc en vérité c'est manichéen ya un
cercle vicieux celui qui est accompagné
par les politiques publiques et la pac
en particulier et le cercle vertueux qui
consiste à refaire rester à remettre de
la matière organique dans les sols pour
que les sols retrouve des réserves
utiles en eau a éveillé effectivement
éviter des sols nus de manière à ce que
on évite que l'agriculture continue de
participer à l'accélération du
dérèglement climatique et qu'au
contraire elle participe à l'atténuer et
on aura aussi beaucoup moins de
difficultés par rapport à haute tension
qui sont actuellement en train de se
mettre en oeuvre autour de la ressource
en eau et ce sur quoi je voulais
insister c'est ce ce cliché qu'on
al'habitude de répandre qui consiste à
dire que par exemple l'agriculture
biologique produit moins que
l'agriculture conventionnelle
ça fait 15 ans que je suis paysan bio ça
fait 15 ans que je produis autant voire
plus que mes voisins qui utilisent de
l'irrigation qui utilisent des
pesticides qui utilisent les engrais de
synthèse c'est juste que l'agriculture
qui est productive c'est l'agriculture
qui fait référence à l'agroécologie qui
prend soin du capital sol qui prend soin
de la biodiversité et qui du coup prend
soin aussi de notre santé donc c'est
encore une fois assez manichéen et je ne
peux plus les cgt membre du conseil
scientifique de l'inra pendant six ans
les études qui visait à vouloir comparer
l'agriculture biologique avec
l'agriculture non non non biologiques
étaient des études dont je pouvais
donner la conclusion avant même de
débuter parce que les protocoles de
comparaison c'est juste scandaleuses ces
protocoles là il faut reprendre de a à z
les logiques agronomique qui font qu'une
agriculture qui s'appuie sur des
logiques agronomique peut facilement
concurrencer une agriculture
conventionnelle et ceux qui résistent et
je vais vous le dire très très
simplement ce qui résiste c'est ce
qu'ils ont intérêt à continuer de nous
vendre des engrais de synthèse des
pesticides pourquoi pas des équipements
d'irrigation mais parce que moi une
agriculture comme celle que je pratique
je suis autonome je n'achète plus de
semences je ne sais plus d'engrais je
n'achète plus de pesticides vous devez
vous douter que je suis pas le grand ami
de bayer ou de saint-jean tas qui
demande par la voix de son directeur de
supprimer l'agriculture biologique
thomas frayant une réaction peut-être
justement sur l'agriculture je pense que
monsieur le député a raison il faut pas
opposer de façon caricaturale
l'agroécologie avec d'autres modèles en
revanche il n'est pas non plus
nécessaire de de caricaturer la
situation géopolitique tel quel et
puisque la russie l'ukraine vu la
production de blé qu'elle représente
représentent les premiers fournisseurs
dead au programme alimentaire mondial et
ce qui est en jeu c'est 200 millions de
personnes qui risquent de subir la
famine ce qui est intéressant dans ce
débat pour bien sortir des logiques
manichéenne et je pense que ça a été dit
avec avec sincérité avec passion il ya
des initiatives qui sont intéressantes à
l'échelle européenne sur ce sujet la
commission et c'est pour ça que la
présence de van der laan sera
intéressante à initier au parlement et
au conseil ce projet de loi sur la
déforestation qui a pour objectif en
effet de créer une responsabilité pas
seulement des producteurs agricoles mais
de tous les producteurs qui pourraient
par leurs activités économiques selon
leur chaîne de valeur jusqu'à des zones
comme l'amérique du sud où l'afrique
aligne dans les chais l'union européenne
provoquée la déforestation importé de la
déforestation puisque en effet
ça représente selon la fao 10 millions
d'hectares par an c'est-à-dire la
surface de l'islande qui est déforester
chaque année et pour ça il n'y a pas
seulement ce travail qui est porté par
l'union européenne parce que c'est un
sujet de commerce mondial qui est bien
posée se tenait la semaine dernière
juste avant la cop15 le congrès
forestier mondial de la fao et j'ai été
effaré d'entendre me dire la directrice
générale déléguée de l'aef à eau que
pour la première fois il allait faire
travailler les ministres des forêts les
miss du commerce ensemble pour pouvoir
enfin avoir des conversations sérieuses
sur la lutte contre la déforestation de
le nombre de chaînes de valeur donc on
voit bien qu'il ya des sujets pour
sortir des débats manica arrêt avant
c'était pas trop dans l'affichage c'est
un problème là je crois qu'on est
vraiment dans le dur plutôt que dans
l'affichage justement quand on se dit au
niveau de la fao il va falloir faire
travailler dans la même pièce les mines
du commerce et les ministres de
l'environnement on sort des caricatures
parce que s'échangent lie ces jours là
ils ont des choses très sérieuses à se
donner il n'ya pas seulement d'ailleurs
que les questions commerciales tout à
l'heure on parle de la lutte contre la
déforestation mais quand on prend le
paysage général de la la dégradation des
sols il ya aussi l'enjeu de la savane
isation qui est l'étape un peu soft
entre guillemets delà de la
désertification puisque là on le sait
aujourd'hui l'amazone i l est en train
de subir un sort qui est gravissime et
le sort qui précède la désertification
c'est la salinisation on sait qu'à
horizon 5 ans on a le poumon de la
planète qui sera sa valise et quand
c'est un problème parce que mbaye
multilatéralisme de coopération est
effectivement on est quand même
aujourd'hui dans un désordre mondial
beaucoup plus qu'un ordre mondial est ce
que ça va pas à l'encontre justement de
ces grandes idées alors que tout le
monde devrait se mettre effectivement
autour de la table qu'ils le font
finalement on n'est plus dans
l'affichage que dans ce cas pas un
problème d'exécution arnaud gautier ça
fait longtemps qu'on parle de
désertification est là aujourd'hui on
tire la sonnette d'alarmé un point oui
non la situation est gravissime c'est on
peut pas on ne peut pas le nier après on
reste on est quand même là sur des
actions qui vont être prises notamment
par la commission européenne c'est un
point très important cette directive sur
la déforestation importé demain si vous
êtes un fabricant de chocolat par
exemple en europe vous devrez prouver
que le cacao qui a servi à fabriquer
votre oeuf de pâques n'a pas provoqué de
déforestation sinon vous ne pourrez pas
importer de cacao en europe est cette
traçabilité est totalement fiable cette
traçabilité aujourd'hui elles existent
sur certaines matières premières pas sûr
déçu et je voudrais je voudrais qu'à
matières premières par exemple sur le
soja elle est complètement imparfaite
style on a eu beaucoup de mal à remonter
jusqu'à la chaîne sur le textile aussi
sur le boeuf aussi on a d'énormes
problèmes leboeuf qui vient du brésil je
parle pas du boeuf fait dans le cantal
mais sur plein de matières premières on
a on a des traçabilité qui sont très
très imparfaite et qui surtout qu'ils
sont liés qui sont laissés aux acteurs
économiques il faut une gouvernance qui
soit supranationale et au dessus des
acteurs économiques et ne pas s'être
gouvernance et sa baie rose même c'est
qui en fait c'est l'union reculé à la
croix la main l'union européenne le lead
résout et terme et mais en mai se met en
position de leader sur la déforestation
à porter et on sait que les normes
édictées par l'union européenne souvent
percole ensuite au niveau mondial c'est
pas systématique mais c'est souvent le
cas je voudrais juste revenir sur un
point très important 2000 qu'a dit
benoît biteau mais faire manger à des
herbivores de l'herbe ça peut paraître
un poncif mais c'est plus sais pas ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en europe on a
60 % des céréales produites ou importées
en europe qui servent à nourrir des
animaux il ya peut-être une hiérarchie à
remettre en place pour lutter pour ces
questions de sécurité alimentaire
mondiale au niveau mondial au niveau
européen d'abord d'abord réservé la
production agricole pour nourrir des
êtres humains ensuite peut-être pour
nourrir des animaux d'élevage et ensuite
pour faire rouler des voitures ou voler
des avions le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que c'est un marché complètement inversé
on va terminer cette émission tout même
en retournant oui vous êtes d'accord
j'imagine arnaud gautier je vous entends
emmanuel seck toujours donc à abidjan
puisque c'était le démarrage de cette
émission puisque c'est là qu'a lieu
cette fameuse case m coop qu'est ce que
vous attendez vous parce que ça va durer
jusqu'au 20 mai cette coop est ce que
vous vous dites pas tout de même que
c'est la quinzième et puis on aura
encore d'autres et finalement voilà à
chaque fois il ya le giec qui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé l'onu ce matin et
finalement les progrès il y en a
quelques-uns ont on l'a vu dans cette
émission mais ils sont tellement
insuffisant est ce qu'il ya un moment où
vous dites vous faut baisser les bras ou
on ne vient pas ces listes
non loin de là je pense que 1 des
intérêts d'avoir ces conférences des
peines de partie c'est surtout
d'interpeller la conscience monial sur
les problématiques ce que l'école que
nous vivons actuellement que ce soit la
sécheresse ou bien d'autres
problématiques relatives au changement
climatique comme l'érosion côtière la
salinisation des terres ou bien les
tempêtes c'est à dire les désastres ces
deux questionnaires aussi quelque part
nous nos modes de production et de
consommation je pense que sur le plateau
cela est revenu souvent nos modes de
production où c'est à dire le profil que
nous recherchons par rapport à
notre production n'est pas favorable à
la durabilité donc ce qu'il faudrait
c'est d'arriver vraiment à résoudre
l'équation profits et durabilité donc si
on arrive à résoudre cette équation là
on devra mais cette équation la bâtiment
a et b 1050 durable et à cette équation
là vous la faites par et house et
plusieurs états qui doivent se mettre
ensemble
nos d'abord ça avoir lieu au niveau
national j'imagine en côte d'ivoire au
sénégal c'est au niveau national mais
mais c'est au niveau national mais aussi
au niveau mondial juste pour vous donner
un exemple si vous le permettez un
coteau culte cotonculteurs par exemple
du sahel lorsque le pays du coton est en
baisse au niveau mondial est obligé de
devra rester pour accroître ses hectares
et avoir il meurt
beaucoup plus important donc vous voyez
que les questions sont liées donc ce que
nous nous attendons pour revenir cela
sur la conférence c'est de vraiment à
voir ce mouvement mondial pour la
restauration des terrains donc pas
uniquement les pays qui sont
effectivement a touché mais que tous les
parties prenantes puissent se sentir
impliqués dans ce processus parce que la
sécheresse qui se déroule en afrique
n'épargne pas disons la méditerranée
avec le mouvement massif de migrants que
vous pouvez comprendre et maintenant si
on investit sur les terres haut niveau
en afrique cela permet de créer de
l'emploi et de fixer au moins les jeunes
au niveau de leur terroir et c'est ce
que je disais auparavant auparavant
c'est à dire qu'on arrive à créer
vraiment des pôles au niveau de ces
collectivités là pour que les jeunes au
lieu de travail par exemple sur une
saison une saison de pluies qui dure
environ trois à cinq mois ci au maximum
maximalise pourrait au moins toute
l'année trouver de l'emploi et aussi
permettre à ce que leurs collectivités
et leurs localités se développe devant
nous c'est ce que nous souhaitons a
ouvert cette année portait davantage ces
sujets-là de la sécheresse de la
désertification au niveau mondial niveau
mondial une fort mouvement de masse il
faut massifier la compréhension et aussi
avoir un engagement fort périodiquement
des pays affectés mais des pays
développés on l'a souvent dit la
question du financement est primordial
la question du financement est présente
sur les scènes ouattara demande 1,5
milliard en tout cas pour la côte
d'ivoire dans le cadre cette coop merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et
emmanuel seck merci beaucoup à vous
benoît biteau également duplex de
bruxelles merci thomas friands merci
beaucoup à nos goûts fier d'avoir été
avec nous merci à tous nos
correspondants qui nous arrange ou nous
ont rejoints lors de cette émission
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
parce qu'avec 9 24
[Musique]